So we use arrays in the Udacity app, for
instance, for course enrollment, right?
Ideally, you'll have more than
one course that you're taking, or
you might be enrolled in a nanodegree,
or set of nanodegrees, and so
those are all stored as
arrays when they come back.
So, I might say that you're in CS 101,
and
you're in an Android course,
for instance.
And both of those will show up as
an array that I parsed through.
Arrays are useful just because when
you have a, like, for instance,
a list of items.
A list of items translates very well
to like a list view or something else.
Generally those are stored in some
type of array data structure.
So I don't use primitive arrays.
But I will use array list for
instance because a lot of the responses
I receive are from the server and
I don't know the exact size of them.
There is a case where maybe a student's
only enrolled in one course but
they could be also
enrolled in a hundred.
So I need to be able to accommodate both
cases and so an array list will allow it
to grow or shrink based on
the response I get from the server.
So, there's several lists we use.
There's a lot of linear lists,
horizontal list,
you see list everywhere
pretty much in it.
So if you think of your again to
enrollments, enrollments is a list view.
If you have a nanodegree,
there's a special nanodegree view
that's also a list view in that case.
And so they're in several places.
Also tracks, tracks within the app
if you are scrolling horizontally.
That's a list view in itself as well.
So recycling views are important because
you want to try to use as little memory
as possible.
So you really only want to render
the views that are on screen in a moment
because a list could potentially
be very large, and so
as you're scrolling through, you're
recycling the views to make sure you're
only rendering what can
fit on that screen.
The way we structure data in
the application is very much
still based on the concepts
you go through in the class.
So we do have the notion of
there's a nanodegree class,
there's a lesson class, there's morsels,
there's all these individual
units that we model as Java
objects within the application.
A lot of times this is kind of,
especially working with an API,
many of those decisions were
already made beforehand,
so because you're consuming an API, it's
already been modeled in a certain sense.
You know what endpoints you're hitting,
you know what the responses are, and
those responses generally are grouped
logically by some type of object.